[Musique]
Ajuster la mèche à travers le nez
amener la province
[Musique]
Pour l'avenir de juillet
Pour l'avenir et la prospérité de notre pays
dont la meilleure tâche est la bonne tâche
ce que tu peux faire
détecter
La détermination d'Erdogan
détermination un leader
tient sa promesse
Parce que c'est une personne qui aime son pays
Parce qu'il aime son pays et son peuple
L'opposition ne peut pas donner confiance aux gens
[Musique]
Kemal Kılıçdaroğlu est une camionnette à changer
système
Idil un dictateur semblable
dans le système avec Kılıçdaroğlu Peut-être est-ce
la démocratie à venir Kılıçdaroğlu Randy
[Musique]
Maintenant, je vais le dire en turc.
Même dans le sens le plus simple du terme, tu sais, mon visage
Je ne veux pas que ça apparaisse parce que, tu sais, un
Parce qu’il n’y a pas de liberté de pensée ici.
Si Erdogan et Erdogan sont dans le pays en ce moment
Il a été divisé en deux sous le nom de Kılıçdaroğlu
Je dis que je veux Kılıçdaroğlu tout de suite.
Parce que j'ai dit, peut-être dans le futur
affaires gouvernementales ou tout autre
J'aurai des difficultés à accéder à leur emploi.
[Musique]
Monde 65 J'ai 64 ans, personne ne me traite de boulot
ça ne donne pas maintenant
Donc les augmentations m'ont surpris car elles n'ont pas donné
Qu’est-ce qui jouait à chaque fois que j’entrais sur le marché?
Tu ne peux pas faire ça, ça ne t'énerve pas tellement
J'étais offensé, je n'allais pas l'utiliser, je l'ai fait.
J'ai vu les rivaux un petit quelque chose de si simple
Ils n’ont donc rien proposé par nécessité.
Alors j'y suis retourné et j'ai utilisé mon esprit
quelque part ou pour l'instant
Kılıçdaroğlu maintenant je ne sais pas du tout
Je ne supprime pas les choses, je mens
Je n'aime pas ça, je veux dire, Mert va vraiment mourir.
Je ne considère pas cela comme un enseignement d’Erdoğan.
Vous direz : " Que s'est-il passé ? Peut-être que nous avons eu des difficultés. "
certains investissements ont été réalisés
[Musique]